good afternoon thanks for joining us at
four i'm kirsten joyce and i'm christian
casadas right now metro police are
working dozens of tips to figure out who
was found inside the barrel at lake mead
now this is a story being shared around
the world first reported right here by
our eight news now i-team metro police
telling us they've received several
dozen tips as they work to identify the
man now he's believed to have been shot
and killed in the late 70s possibly
early 80s now you can submit a tip by
calling metro or through crime stoppers
well the case is being investigated as a
homicide though the circumstances of the
crime are unknown some are speculating
that this could be mobility joe moeller
spoke to an executive director at the
mob museum who says he's keeping a close
eye on this joe joins us live at the
museum with what was shared joe
well just like all of us the one
historian here at the mob museum has a
lot of questions about this case he says
it is very possible this could be a mob
related death
killing somebody and putting them in a
barrel and dumping them
in water is actually a common mob tactic
going back to the 1800s this is
something that's very you know almost
common if you look at it over a long
period of time while we don't know if
the death is mob related minnie can't
help but wonder if it is a body found in
a barrel police believe the victim
inside was shot in the 70s or 80s
historian jeff schumacher is the vice
president of exhibits and programs at
the mo museum he says bodies of many
mobsters were killed in the same way
throughout history it may not be a mob
hit it may be somebody who sort of
copied the tactics of the mob but when
we're talking about the era 1970s 1980s
the mob was pretty prominent in las
vegas at that time and it was a time of
a lot of conflicts as well so there were
people who went missing he says
regardless of who committed the crime
the circumstances around this case could
provide answers for a decades old
mystery
i also spoke to a detective from that
time as well he says this discovery does
not come as a surprise schumacher says
they will be keeping a close eye on this
case to see if here at the mom museum
they can help at all reporting live in
downtown las vegas joan muller live
local now